so uh i loved your trailer when are when
are fans going to be able to see it the
trailer is coming soon i can't say when
we're going to unleash the bros trailer
soon
they would kill me if i told you one day
so i can't but very soon and i'm very
excited for people to see it uh i love
nick stoller he's your director he is on
my co-writer
exactly um can you talk a little bit
about why nick was the right person for
helping the film and
nick came to me
and said uh in september of 2017 nick
stoller came to me we'd worked together
before and he said i want my next movie
to be a rom-com i love rom-coms but i
want to make one about a gay couple but
he said i'm not gay because he's very
straight so do you want to write it with
me and you can star on it and i'll
direct it and no one has ever asked me
to write a movie or
star in a movie or anything like that
and so i just said yes knowing it was a
huge opportunity but having no idea
what the movie would be about or whether
i could pull it off and so i'm very
grateful to nick for believing in me and
i think
there was something about him being
straight and me being gay that i think
ended up being
uh the right alchemy to tell this story
in a way that would be authentic to gay
people but also relatable to everyone
uh
one of the things obviously many films
change in the editing room what did you
guys learn when you were test screening
that maybe impacted the finished film
um what did we learn when we were test
screening well nick and i
love jokes it was very important to us
to do a comedy that made people
consistently laugh out loud i think it's
been a really long time since people
went to a movie theater and
just laughed a lot you know we get a lot
of things sold to us
on streamers that are supposed to be
comedies but
they're they didn't remind me of the
comedies of our youth and the rom-coms
of my youth like
when harry met sally and moonstruck and
tootsie and annie hall and uh broadcast
news and all these movies that were
rom-coms but held themselves to a very
high standard so i'm not saying we met
that level with bros because those are
classic movies and i'm not saying that
but we try to hold ourselves to that
standard but what we realized during the
test screening is that
although people's main reaction was that
oh wow it's really funny
people were surprisingly moved by the
film and i think that has something to
do with the fact that
there just haven't been many movies
especially many comedies many romantic
comedies that centered around a gay
couple so it's new for straight people
and it's new for gay people and there's
something about that i think
really hits people and and i've been
i've been surprised
delighted but surprised by how moved
people are in addition to
laughing
um
[Music]
what uh my last thing for you obviously
because i got thrown off by the last
question you don't want to talk right
now
one of the things that i found that
really refreshing in the trailer was
that you're not shying away from showing
sex yeah and can you sort of talk about
that making sure you wanted to actually
include that
yeah it was important to me it's a part
of life you know it's a part of dating
for straight people for gay people for
bi people for everyone and
we're making a romantic comedy sex is
romantic and it's also really funny you
know we take sex very seriously but you
know sex can be really funny and how can
you do a story about two people falling
for each other and not deal with sex
there's so much to mine from that and
also i will say
gay people gay men
we just haven't had many stories where
sex was funny and romantic
without it being something like dirty
it's like we've had we've either had
like two-dimensional sitcom characters
who talked about sex but in a very
cartoonish way that didn't feel real or
we have porn
you know there's nothing in between that
feels human and real and so it was
important for us to include that and i
think it's the authenticity of the movie
that's making everyone straight people
gay people
really
uh
come alive when they see it and really
be thrilled by it and and they think
it's funny too there was one straight
guy at a test screening who loved the
movie he was like yeah the sex scenes
were like jackass
like they made me a little uncomfortable
but it was so funny i didn't care and i
was like great i'll take it on that note
sir thank you for your time thank you
you